we never ever had the intentions of
killing anybody admittedly we wanted to
hurt the people for what what they did
to that kid you know as I've knocked on
the door the BS are answered and
uh I don't know why
but he threw me a pants I got a gun on
him and and the
rest was just in instantaneous you know
instinct
[Music]
I was born in uh North London chalk Farm
1948 and uh pretty poverty stricken
childhood there was seven of us in two
rooms my dad was in prison quite a lot
my mom couldn't cope with all the kids
you know so it was a bit uh but you
don't know any different when you're a
kid you it's
uh it's only when you look back on it
you think oh that was tough you know
people were a lot more friendly then
nobody locked their front doors was
always hard for Brick holding the door
open in the street you could go into any
house to escape from the police or
whatever Cav or
whatever yeah was more
neighor and what were you like as a as a
child a bloody nuisance I should imagine
I I noticed when you're in like primary
school and Nursery or things like that
they required you to sleep after lunch
and all which was completely impossible
for me so uh I became a bit of a
headache to him one of my um friends I
used to play TR with was Cat Stevens
who's his name is Steven Georgie when I
knew him but we used to go and book in
it morning register and then just off
you know wonder about London all
day yeah your mother left you in care
and then you went to an approved School
uh approved school was the first one
yeah that was mainly because um well you
could get a proof School in them days
just a playing T you know from school
they all mostly run on threats and
brutality you know I how they kept their
order there was
uh well things they did in them days but
today is considered child abuse you know
I didn't consciously choose to lead a
criminal life it was just the
environment and
uh and the people around
me and how long were you in those kind
of Institutions for
um well after a series of children's own
I went to Pro school that lasted about 2
and a half
years and then after that there was
B which is run on a sort of military
style basis boots and Gators you know
Maring around and
again uh the end threat was brutality
you
know but I seen escape from everywhere
they bang me up you
know I escape from B about three
times I don't know for me as a kid who
was just used to running free round the
streets being locked up was
unnatural funny enough it was my spell B
where I I met a few friends I happened
to bump into one in later in later years
when I when I got out who seemed to be
doing quite well and uh he invited me to
join
them uh and it turned out it
was they were bank robbers you know I
started off as a driver cuz people
recognized the ability of driving and
what have you then you slowly progressed
to working for firms in North London
South Lon East Lon West
London and it got to the stage where
um we just got tired of jump out the
backs of transit six-handed or
whatever and by the time you had the cut
up it never seemed
to be much of a payback for what you for
the chances you were taking you know so
we decided to leave them dispens with uh
shotguns and stealing cars and all that
sort of stuff so bought handguns and
shoulder alers bought the cars out the
evening news and we just should go out
dressed up just cruising we could even
stay in the pool for the whole build
you and as soon as we spotted
a security van pulling up we jump out
and have it on the spot you
know sometimes we might have two in one
day or whatever so it came to a point we
we just didn't know what to do with all
the money everywhere was overflowing
money we bought houses cars boats but
and we decided
we better
retire so I I'd moved out to Kent bought
a house out
there and uh I remember sitting in the
garden when the phone went it was he my
power pH me up he said how you doing
John I said that said I'm fuing bored
you know he said so am I he saidu get
the tools out let's go to work we were
supposed to have met a guy in a pub had
a couple of business bu for sale we
thought well if we can buy a few
businesses we get a legal income and
then we can really retire you know but
the guy didn't show up and by the time
we realized he's not going to show we'd
had a few drinks sort of got the flavor
stayed out we ended up at this club in
heckley called The
Cricket any I I don't know why it was
but somebody took Umbridge and us
because they thought we was a bit true
fles cuz we was buying everybody drinks
but we just wanted to keep that party
atmosphere going you know everyone was
enjoying themselves there was a few
Muppets down there suddenly it kicked
off anyhow we me and my P we sort of
fought our way to the door and got out
but as we're halfway up the
stairs we've heard these blood curling
screams coming from within you so
realized there was an acquaintance of
his been left behind just a young kid
named John D his name was out with his
girlfriend and so oh he's he's still in
there so we had to fight our way back in
and uh bet I
must iterate that we never ever had the
intentions of killing anybody admittedly
we wanted to hurt the people for what
what they did to that kid you know
but
um as I've knocked on the door the BS
are answered and
uh I don't know why
but he threw me a punch I got a gun on
him and and the
rest was just in instantaneous you know
Instinct that didn't stop the forward
momentum just carried on into the club
and looking for the other perpetrators
you know
and uh our frustration sort of shut the
bar up
and just vertually terrified everybody
you
know
um me being me I just didn't know when
to give up you
know so uh I was still armed at the
time and that you didn't have the
prevalence of armed polies You' got
today so fortunately for me they weren't
armed so they
scared so I jumped back in the as mine
and batted the car out of the
driveway but I'm now in the street but I
can't get past a Rover and a police van
like that so I don't know why they I
just fired it the blue light on the top
and the car reversed about 30 mph you
couldn't even see the
driver that was what I got arrested
for and got life sentence for murder
yeah so you got life murder got life for
a minimum of 20 years how did you feel
when you received that verdict uh I
didn't really know what a life sentence
was either but I do remember is still a
bit of a
shock and uh I know my family were in
pieces over it you
know but
um I know it it was what it was I just
had to get on with it you know I went to
Brixton on
remand and then they quickly took me out
of
there and sent me to
onth from W I went to the W
scrubs and from W scrubs they sent me up
to wake field and I've actually did a
tour of the whole British I every prison
I've lost count of the prisons I went
to of course they made me K
A which is supposed to be uh if you were
to escape you'd be an embarrassment to
the government and a danger to the
public
orever in the early days you you
couldn't move you you were literally
escorted
everywhere with a dog handler and four
screws you
know the only be
you got to the front of the queue on
everything you know you got fed first
you got your can
first but
um you literally couldn't breathe in
there checking on you every qu an hour
you had to move s every 3
months in case you were digging a tunnel
you could never finish it you
know so it was all uh everything was
uprooting all the time you could never
sell the funny thing with me I think
what helped me immensely through that
sentence was my brother Terry he was
only 10 months younger than
me and uh he committed suicide at the
beginning of my
sentence and uh it completely knocked me
for six you know I couldn't get me head
around it it left me with no fear to
face the opposition as you know schools
come in to give me a hide in I'd run
walls them rather than run
away
and being the cows that they
are well I had six Sol years of
brutality and in the end they just gave
up on it which I if it weren for my
fitness or whatever I don't think I
would have survived it some of them
screws are about 20 stone you know I
mean when they sit on your chest you got
you're in danger of getting crushed
rupture spleen or whatever which I know
has happened to a few
guys for the most part the school all EX
squaders in them days big fat beard guts
you know they they can only have a r for
about 30 seconds and they're all puffing
and paning you know the worst prison I
ever for that was place up in Yorkshire
called armley was a local jail and out a
spy one day and said mie we're coming in
a minute we're going to break your
back and uh I said Oh Come and then get
on and uh it's not long before to
overpower you had to come in with in the
early days you used to be a mattress but
now they got these plastic Shields
and sort of body armor and all that sort
of stuff but the handcuffing be arm me
back and then they drag you down the
stairs to the segregation unit by your
feet so that your head it's every step
on the way down you know and I
actually got amnesia once I woke up in a
strong
box I could remember but my own
name I think it wasn't until for about 3
weeks I started piecing things together
you
know were you able to form relationships
with your fellow prisoners if you were
being moved around so much did you find
friendships in there yeah I had friends
where one but the beauty of the old days
with your
old your sort of old gangsters and your
old bank robbers with no matter where
you got transferred in the country
there'd always be someone there that
knew you was
coming and uh meet you at the gate or
whatever we settle you in see that
you're all right I remember got the
first time went to Park House it was
regie crater first may we took carry
back full of goodies which is nice you
know to today you get in prison it's Dog
Eat Dog they don't give a
you sort of got to find your own
way so obviously your sentence did get
extended while you in prison yeah was it
three or four Total escape attempts that
you I think it was four together when I
when I first
uh in I think it was
after a year or two I got a visit and my
curiosity got the better on me I had to
it was a police
visit they try to offer me 5 years and
out I said look we take your chisik
police station you'll have a sweet of s
you can do what you like have your own
food you can have your wife your
girlfriend but you got to cough up your
mates and uh well you know what my
answer was I don't think it would have
matter the length of a sentence I just
think it's unnatural be locked
up and uh they're their they're their
rules they not my rules they're man-made
laws they I didn't make them God did
make
them and uh but the main thing that
drove me
was
family uh for instance my lest came from
penville I begged and pleaded with the
governor to allow me to go and see my
mother who was dying from a brain
tumor and it was like a talk a brick
wall just
refused is it true at penville you you
just like threw a rope over the wall and
no it's was easy I think the newspapers
tried to stereotype it by saying they
naed cheets hanging over the wall and
all that ASO nonsense
so um uh I was head done by the gym
staff to to build uh an office
roof plus uh I was B handy with the
tools and maintain the gym
equipment which
uh gave me access to the tool
cupboard and uh but I'd already started
that job before I got refused permission
to go see me m by the time I decided
they weren't going to allow me I was
already quite embedded in the gym as Jim
oldy and um I thought I I'm going to get
out so
uh the the staff toilets and showers and
that when had a washing machine that
which we were allowed to use a wash a
gym kit I noticed there was a A trapo in
the
ceiling with a padlock and bolt on
it
[Music]
um so I managed to leave the bolt so it
bypass the
padlock and I got up into the LOF space
for about 10 minutes a day with the
spanners undoing the
bars and they was heavier must have
weighed about 400 weight These Bars I
remember when I got the final bow out I
had to struggle and let it down gently
if i' have dropped it it gone right for
the and it had all all been on top you
know but underneath the bars there was a
sort of square tunnel with a a
concrete glass Skylight above it and
from the cell block I used should be
able to see out the window onto the roof
of the
gym and I could tell that I could get
through that you
know so over a period I I managed to get
equipment up into the love
space and get to work on on the
Skylight but the beauty of that was I
bypassed all the razor wire all the
cameras cuz I'm coming out the roof and
not going over it so went I was on top
of the roof you got about 2 foot of wall
left high and I'm terrified of fights I
remember calling on all fours across a
mway bridge bus because I had Vero yeah
so I knew that I had
to get over that more quickly I was I'd
never make it so I tied a bit of rope
around me arm from a f Side gold
Puffs and as I come out of the Skylight
without looking I just dive straight
over the way on to this bit of
string and
uh but I not falling three quarters away
cuzz it unraveled too quick you
know and uh unfortunately I landed about
10t away from the screw going
home and but luckily for me he was uh a
mild man guy he wasn't a landing screws
he worked in the stores I know him quite
well his name was George when he found
his voice he started joh John what the
hell do you think you're
doing I just said sorry George I Ain got
a time to Rabbit and I just flew past
him over the wall to the flats and the
way
I got
away and I got to see my mom and the
smile on her face was beautific when she
saw me and there something they can
never ever take away from
me and I said to you I did it had you
let me out I'd have come back on my
own and each time you escaped was your
sentence extended yeah of course uh well
as you as you know a Life
Center well take for instance my
codefendant only served 14
years
and I've actually done three times
that so and I got a minimum of 20 right
so I so I more than doubled
that I did 23 years more than the
minimum but the thing is there's no
maximum you can get a minimum sense but
there's no
ceiling you can literally stay in prison
till the day you die which I was
threatened with many a time you're going
to die in prison messy unless you give
it a free B for yes sir no sir all that
which is just against my
nature yeah do you regret your escapes
no
now I'll do it all over again you look
any any living creature up in a
cage first thing it does is circle that
cage looking for a weakness doesn't it I
mean even a plant you put in a dark
corner it will grow towards the
light so to threaten people with
uh more prison if you attempt to escape
in prison just seems ludicrous to me
and it never deterred me
anyway for a time I think for 40 we
served 43 years and I think that made
you England's longest serving prisoner
yeah how did it feel to know well that
was a title I certainly didn't want no I
mean uh people get saying I like Bon's
well he can have it he can have it with
jam on top I don't want it you know
but
um I thought how can I be the worst
roaman British house I can't be you know
you got this crazy you had the rich you
had and you got all these child killers
and genocide
people why am I top dog that tells me
that they're saying I'm worse than all
the rest of them and I refused to
believe that
I'm you know
and you were released in 2018 how was
the the lead up to your release in their
wisdom they almost decided that I should
be banned from category D prisons open
prisons so I had to go to this new
guinea pig of uh I think it was blany I
don't
know uh called Warren warrren Hill it's
in nor or a church
somewhere again it's um
it was enclosed it it was a wall around
or fence around it and you had to go
through these courses
stages and complete it to stage three or
whatever it was then you got a parole
board and you stood a chance of getting
out you
know and also I grew this beard as well
cuz every par board I ever went on on
the top of the record sitting on the
desk was a young picture of
me and I thought myself they keep
looking at that photograph if it are
this he can he looks young and fair he
could do another 10 stret you so I gow
this beard looking old and I watch in a
bit do yeah L beh older got
parole so I couldn't couldn't really
believe
it how did it feel being
free like being boring yeah it was
lovely I I still got a picture of my
sister and my niece meeting me outside
the gate and you look at that picture
you can't help but smile cuz the smiles
on their faces
just glow with happiness you
know yeah it was
great how old were you when you went
into prison I 26 when I went in I was 70
when I come
out or there about
yeah I'm 75
now I suppose you can never get all that
time that you served back but no I'm not
I'm never going to live as long as I
spent in prison
now but uh it's no good C spelled mil
what done is done you
know just got to make the best of what's
left and what are you you spending your
time doing that I I still did the odd
job comment Tre and that which I enjoy
it's not a lot of work for me it's it's
more of a
hobby and
um I go to the gym every
day I've got
a
fantastic
partner things are good pretty good yeah
but I I find um I'm often enough have I
got um a message for like young kids or
whatever sort
of making their way into that sort of
life I I really find that you
can't get through to
him maybe something
like but
he even something like that
as uh so traumatic as that sentence was
you got young kids out there they're
going to find think there's some sort of
Glamour in it that is absolutely not it
certainly isn't
glamorous and
uh I because I although getting released
was nice it was
lovely I
still get hit
unexpectedly with things that trigger
bad memories
and and I have a bad time over it you
know even at here each day is a battle
you have with your own
mind what you've lost and what youve
sacrifice what you're never ever going
to get
back and uh and the people that are not
here
anymore you know you still expect the
door open to open them certain family
members to walk in that it's never going
to
happen and it hits you hard you
know but um even though now I'm ens
being I'm free I'm not I'm on a piece of
string I can trag me back to prison any
time they're
like well I suppose they got to have a
valid reason
but as we all know they can make up
those reasons whenever they feel like
it so you never free that uh life
sentence carries a life
license there's no end to
it the day I'm truly free is the day of
a
[Music]
DI I had to strip down to next to
nothing Greer put a t over the cut
section of bar off the window so I
wouldn't scratch my back and levered
myself out while Sten wrenched that up
just another little inch probably
strangling everybody he'd always hated
since childhood but just enough for me
to get out